some more news um that is out there
besides will smith
and
chris rock that is affecting our world
uh john eastman
um
there's a few contempt charges it looks
like breaking a judge orders john
eastman to release his emails he
attempted to withhold from the january
6th select committee
trump's plan had worked it would have
permanently ended the peaceful transfer
of power undermining american democracy
so it looks like kyle is reporting here
that john eastman
uh is going to be ordered to release his
emails
that involve the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup we also seen over the weekend that
was buried in the will smith chris rock
news um that there were a few contempt
charges from peter navarro and dan
scavino jr that were issued it looks
like the january 6 select committee may
hold them in contempt um let's see
let's either hugo has a breaking federal
judge orders trump lawyer john eastman
to release emails to january 6th select
committee saying the court finds more
likely than not trump and eastman
dishonestly conspire to obstruct the
joint session of congress
which is uh possibly a conspiracy of
sedition ah don't you think hmm
sounds familiar oath keepers and proud
boys uh maybe even has something to do
with roger stone wouldn't you think
um i believe we're getting closer and
closer aaron says here
uh wow read this line from the ruling
today ordering that john eastman
releases emails
to the january 6 committee uh the court
finds that more than likely that not
that
then excuse me the court finds it more
likely than not that president trump
corruptly attempted
corruptly attempted to instruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
is the quote from the court filing aaron
reports here
and this is this is very significant and
the reason why it's significant is the
judge is not just talking about john
eastman
this is a conspiracy we've seen this
word before in these federal indictments
in these federal indictments we have
seen this word before conspiracy to
commit sedition
we have 11 oath keepers um several proud
boys that are charged with seditious
conspiracy we seen that these um oath
keepers and the proud boys met in a
parking garage enrique tario and stewart
rhodes the founder of the oath keepers
and and the leader of the proud boys at
the time
or meeting in a parking garage to
conspire with sedition
where we seen
one of those proud boys who has pled
guilty
to seditious conspiracy
who the day of january 6
that the judge is saying
that there was a corrupt attempt to
obstruct the joint session of congress
to certify the results
one of those oath keepers joshua james
has pled guilty in the federal court
the thing funny thing about joshua james
if you didn't know which i'm sure you do
is he was he was uh
tasked
with the personal protection of roger
stone
that day on january 6th
roger stone as you know is the personal
friend and confidant
of
and uh a
pardon recipient
of donald j trump the president at the
time on january 6 who called
to action the insurrection
and you had the proud boys and the oath
keepers on standby so much so that they
were defending his personal competent
who may or may not have been in personal
contact with the president united states
we seen we seen that jeannie thomas was
in contact with the chief of staff mark
meadows why in the [ __ ] is it so hard to
believe that roger stone would have had
a direct line to the president of the
united states
why is that so hard to believe
i don't think it's that hard to believe
i don't actually don't think it's far
stretch
that roger stone and donald trump were
communicating that day
or the day before the day after during
the insurrection even
while he was receiving
roger stone that is protection
from one of the oath keepers who's pled
guilty and seditious conspiracy which it
seems like john eastman
and donald trump
are now being accused in a federal court
of some sort of seditious conspiracy
the court finds that it is more likely
than not
based on the evidence of the emails this
is not like the court's guessing the
court saw the emails and the saying the
court finds it more than likely than not
that the president of the united states
at the time the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants the orange mussolini
jesus himself
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress they stopped
short of saying he's part of the
seditious conspiracy i'm guessing
they're leaving it up to prosecutors at
the doj
hmm
so bring on bring on more of the merrick
garland talk
i know that's what's going to happen
here here's lawrence tribe
of course i'm not even going to read
that garbage i know where that's going
um and we have spiro agnes ghost here
breaking in his ruling against trump's
attorney john eastman the judge says
it's more than likely than not that
trump committed crimes including felony
obstruction of congress on one sixth the
judge blatantly described their behavior
as attempt of coup in search of legal
theory
in other words it's all [ __ ] they
were just trying they were just throwing
spaghetti at the
at the wall here the cheeto dust
spaghetti at the wall
right
um so this is the breaking news uh you
know what we have someone here uh that
might be able to give us a little bit of
insight into this breaking news um
if she is she ready
is she ready to join us are you can you
give me a thumbs up yeah
rachel bitcoffer hey rachel how are you
ah dude i'm pretty pretty excited how
about you
oh i i i just we're just seeing this
breaking news
um on the show here
we were talking of course you know we
were talking about the slap heard around
the world but this slap is the one that
has to be heard around the world
and uh maybe maybe just maybe if we talk
about will smith and chris rock enough
and then follow it up with this uh
people here you know i actually i
actually i think i i sent you some stuff
earlier saying uh people think thinking
that you can't talk about will smith and
chris rock in the context of what's
happening in our country is what's wrong
with liberals like liberals in this
country don't understand like
republicans in the right have bonded
like welded pop culture and their
politics together and that's the left
misses they don't they don't understand
that you can do two things at once and
you should weld these things together
because that's how we get people to pay
attention to things like i don't know
government and politics otherwise they
don't know who the vice president is
they don't know who the attorney general
is they don't know that there's a
federal case being had against john
eastman the the the architect of the
cheeto dust kangaroo which and in this
statement right here in this slap heard
around the world from the judge which
should be the slap heard around the
world uh will smith if you're listening
this judge did a hell of a lot better
job of slapping john eastman and donald
trump that you ever could dream of of
slapping chris rock on stage
but here's what i'll tell you here's
what i'll tell you um john eastman and
not only john eastman is implicated it
looks like in this judge's decision but
also donald trump as well they they
stopped short of saying
seditious conspiracy here um as i
noticed but they are uh very strongly
pointing towards that these are
these are felonies these are crimes and
they should be convicted of these crimes
um do you think that this is maybe you
know that we get a lot of fodder from
people saying oh the department of
justice and merrick garland aren't doing
their jobs and that's all anti-democracy
talk because i think when you when when
you as a pro-democracy person disparage
an institution and a person like merrick
garland you are doing democracy
disservice you're actually on the side
of autocracy when you want some one
person to have a magic wand to prosecute
anyone anywhere whenever you want for
whatever you want there is due process
in this country regardless i mean
our justice system isn't perfect and we
know there's a lot of problems that need
to be fixed but for for anyone out there
to take the the uh uh
the authoritarian stance on the
department of justice is not doing
democracy a favor but i actually believe
that this
this is groundbreaking like this is the
the
possible st the first nail in donald
trump's coffin here for january 6
because he's got a lot of other problems
with his business in new york and
possible voter voter intimidation
georgia this here is a problem that is
going to be huge because there's
something they're hiding don't you think
tony damn you're in fine form and nobody
here would know you spent all weekend
puking your balls off wow that's true i
i was i was i did have a little stomach
bug this weekend but it was like the 24
hour thing so i'm going wow that's my
favorite kind because at least you have
the clock right that's right that's
right and it happened and it happened
over the weekend so
couldn't have been perfect for
saturday yeah i like the weekend stomach
it
was
my
flu too because i can't afford to miss a
monday for friday right now that's right
that's right i can't either two hours
every single day right here nobody else
to do your [ __ ] for you and neither do i
okay
so tell us tell us why you think this is
so big
this is huge it is the slap heard around
the world and you know what's really
[ __ ] up about it guys all this all
y'all audience too
is to understand that i just randomly
picked john eastman out today when i
tweeted that [ __ ] out dude i was like oh
wouldn't it be nice if will smith had
smack john eastman because then people
would actually know who the [ __ ] he is
right right
a serendipity that like here's three
hours later and this [ __ ] big ass
news comes out about eastman and it
really does it is the slap and tony
you're absolutely right like i i try to
be uniform about it i don't i'm not
always great sometimes i'll celebrate
something i feel guilty about later you
know like a crowd interrupting a speaker
just because they're yelling [ __ ]
fascism or whatever you know and
no one's perfect but at the end of the
day i do try to always keep people's
comment to keep people to understand
like listen dude the justice department
isn't going to just come out with their
dick swinging and leave it all in the
air if you want to make a case
especially these kinds of cases which
will be litigated in a there's no
precedent for this litigation
probably the closest [ __ ] thing you
could think of would be john adams
defending the the boston massacre you
know soldiers before under an old system
of government because this is just
really
very it's it's taking the doj into a
realm it's not been in before and i and
i i do want people to understand like
when you
say things about the process or that
he's corrupt i mean i i wanted some
attention to go on brag and i think that
he's a fool to not [ __ ] uh let the
indictments and the grand juries go on
in manhattan but i don't think it's
because he's getting money from donald
trump right i think it's just that he
doesn't have the political balls to go
to town with this kind of stuff so you
know
which there's processes in new york that
that that the governor has to make sure
that if if that if that indictment needs
to happen in new york the governor of
new york has the ability to make that
indict not make it happen but to make
sure there's someone there that has the
as you say political balls to to uh seek
that indictment if there was crimes
committed especially against the state
in new york the governor has the right
now not only that is that tish james is
bringing a civil lawsuit that is um for
people to know tis james is the one that
handy that kneecap the trump foundation
right yeah she basically brought it down
like like the trump casino um
and
when when it came down crashing to the
ground
and she's going to do the same thing her
mission is do the same thing to the
trump organization and the reason why is
because it's a total [ __ ] fraud he is
a fraud his business is a fraud him
being a billionaire is a [ __ ] fraud
president sees the fraud his support is
a fraud we've seen that over the weekend
with the trump rally which i i don't
mean to go all the way back to the trump
rally but let me tell you i actually i
actually think that that trump rally has
a lot to do with this decision that's
being made today um and the reason why
is because donald trump is hell-bent on
the american people believing that he's
going to run in 2024 now regardless if
he does because they definitely don't
want to make the conversation right now
about 2022 they want to make it about
2024. that is clear i mean some of the
despicable vile [ __ ] that was spewed
at that rally this weekend um not only
is uh
just disgusting
but it's some of the [ __ ] that came out
of marjory taylor green's mouth no doubt
and if you're if you're not aware
that that the fascists are coming after
you they're they're right around the
corner for you they're coming after
[ __ ] bicycles for crying out loud if
your kid rides a bike they're coming
after your [ __ ] kid with a bicycle
they hate bicycles they're the liberal
enemy now but i'll tell you that i think
i think that their their mission is to
distract their voters and their
constituency from things like this that
they were trying to overthrow the
government they were the ones trying to
commit a coup they were the ones that
are trying to install a dictator and it
and all this fodder about joe biden
somehow
you know the the world's sleepiest
mastermind i don't i can't understand
this [ __ ] um but he's the world's
sleepiest mastermind is all nonsense and
they're trying to distract their
constituency their vote
because that's all they've got that's
all they've got because it's only gonna
peel away from the country
as they discover
that john eastman and donald trump
conspired as a judge here says
coup in search of a legal theory which
is uh a choice of words i believe that
is a that is that is the quote right
there right and if i hadn't been driving
i would have already tweeted that quote
out because it's just i mean it just
says it all right i mean this is a coup
in search of a legal rationale
right yeah
well it was from the beginning and
really um they they had a lot of straws
that they were trying to draw from right
they were trying to do the whole a
supreme court is gonna decide this and
making crown a king um they tried inside
the state the state legislators to try
to have alternative electors which is
probably going to people go to federal
prison
the extent and the complexity of this
plot across not only all three branches
of government as the ginny thomas and uh
stuff
you know makes clear so it's not just
the federal legislative and judicial
federal
part executive uh branches of the
federal government what we're talking
about then is the that's that goes down
into all of these state parties right
especially in the most um
pivotal states georgia arizona michigan
pennsylvania wisconsin uh arizona if i
didn't say that it those that criminal
conspiracy
is so widespread that i i have long
argued that that there is no choice but
for doj to pursue the rule of law here
because to put it aside and say oh well
it's in the past like george bush's
torture
stuff
there's no america if if this
coup lot because it's so extensive so
it's so intentional it is you know put
into checks multiple checks to try to
overthrow the election as you were just
talking about
it is a such a travesty of rule of law
that america cannot exist without
enforcement of the law here right right
well and and i i bel i believe they are
doing that because we we not only i mean
to say the department of justice is
sitting on their hands is a little
ridiculous they started from the actual
literal bottom of
of the conspiracy and have charged and
people are have their bare feet on a
cold floor in a prison right now
who broke windows at the capitol who
physically broke the windows at the
capitol for people who conspired for the
people who conspired to overturn our
government and [ __ ] on our constitution
and tear it and shred it into pieces and
make us a fascist state and they still
want to do that folks they're not done
they're not done with the coup
they're still there they what we watch
matt gatt stand on stage to introduce
the cheeto dust mobster himself this
weekend and say that he want a sex
trafficker an accused sex trafficker by
the way is going to nominate a [ __ ]
grabber for the speaker of the house and
he is proud of it and donald trump came
up and went wow that's [ __ ] crazy
even donald trump was like
that's [ __ ] insane he couldn't even
believe that matt gatz was saying that
[ __ ] and that's
about listen because only because he is
mostly unstrategic but he's not a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right and so like the one
thing that he's wanted like people not
to talk about it and this is why i
always talk about it is the fact that he
intends to become speaker of the house
he has no other play that can possibly
keep him insulated from legal stuff no
other access point back into the public
debate
and that's what he wants more than any
[ __ ] thing right probably over legal
immunity he wants to be in that position
right where he
can't be
siloed out like uh in uh you know
superman out into that world
in space like that's basically where
donald trump exists in the one [ __ ]
thing he cares about which is attention
right and so um the last thing he needed
was mccarthy being reminded of that
vulnerability right now while he's
puppet stringing him and i'm sure donald
trump was at that moment thinking that
well and and i i actually think that it
would it would cause a bunch of uh
disruption in donald trump's ego to go
from president of speaker the house but
i think if he could be convinced like
you're saying that he would be insulated
he would totally take he would totally
take that downgrade um and do that
there's literally nothing better for egg
if you think about being him and he's
just an evil [ __ ] up little con man
then think about like what that would
afford him then he can introduce
[ __ ] fake impeachment charges
against um it would be an onslaught and
and granted granted even if it would
happen i'm not saying that our country
would lose which we would lose badly um
but i am saying that we we would abs
think about how [ __ ] irresponsible
and how lazy that piece of [ __ ] is we
would the house of representatives would
come to a full stop of nothing nothing
would get done we wouldn't appropriate
any funds our government would fall our
credit rating would fall
regardless tony i mean people need to
[ __ ] understand with the republican
party takes control of the house of
representatives they just plowed through
500 000 people excess in covet deaths so
that they could attack democrats and
attack joe biden and undermine the
coveted response once biden was sworn in
and the vaccine came out they will not
stop
right and they it doesn't matter if it's
mccarthy
mtg
uh paul gosar donald trump i mean it
doesn't [ __ ] matter whoever that next
speaker is do not expect government to
function
right well they don't want government
that's the whole point like they don't
want it
their goal is to spark a crisis right
democracy is bad for them just like in
ukraine democracy is bad for putin
that's why they love putin that's why
they love the putin on the world stage
and that's why they hate democracy and
that's why they say [ __ ] like we're not
a democracy we're a republic we are a
constitutional democratic republic we
are a [ __ ] democracy get a dictionary
out dust that son of a [ __ ] off and
read the definitions to words rachel
thanks for joining us we are at the end
of the show i appreciate you coming in
beautiful beautiful beautiful we love
when you join us everyone tomorrow join
us again live on youtube twitter twitch
and now on the facebook uh midas touch
facebook page noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific don't miss it every single
weekday monday through friday until
tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]